[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und marietta slomka
guten abend wir wissen noch nicht wie
historiker künftig die epoche nennen
werde die wir im moment erleben
vielleicht den zweiten ost-west-konflikt
oder kalter krieg 3.0 darauf stellt sich
die nato jedenfalls ein und das bringt
gewaltige veränderungen mit sich die man
auch hierzulande spüren wird nicht nur
durch die neue stationierung
amerikanischer soldaten die joe biden
heute ankündigte die zeit in der
deutsche bundesregierung die bundeswehr
als eine art mobile eingreiftruppe
betrachteten schlank ausgestattet sind
vorbei das wird aufgerüstet werden
zurück zu klassische landesverteidigung
bei der man nicht an einsätzen
hindukusch denkt sondern an
panzerschlachten in der norddeutschen
tiefebene oder zerstörer in der ostsee
florian neumann berichtet von diesem
nato gipfel
dass sie hier bisher nur gast ist was
könnte das besser verdeutlichen als
diese kleine frage bei der ankunft sind
sie die premierministerin
an die schwedische ministerpräsidentin
magdalene anders schon und an irland
wird man sich gewöhnen müssen weil
schweden genau wie finnland künftig wohl
dazu gehört zur nato
heute ist ein historischer tag für
schweden für das schwedische volk
sie kann das heute sagen weil der
türkische präsident erdogan offenbar
bekommen hat was er im gegenzug für sein
okay wollte zum beispiel das
zugeständnis dass schweden und finnland
ihr waffenembargo gegen die türkei
aufheben eine kleine erpressung unter
künftigen verbündeten die anstehenden
ort erweiterung der nato nur ein
nebenprodukt dieses gipfels für den die
madrilenen ihre stadt ein paar tage
anderen überlassen müssen und auf dem
die nato sich völlig neu ausrichtet ihr
bisheriges strategisches konzept
beschlossen in einem anderen zeitalter
lissabon 2010 damals ist der russische
präsident medwedew zu gast die nato
erklärt russland zum strategischen
partner
was für ein kontrast
unser neues konzept unterscheidet sich
sehr von dem damals es macht klar dass
russland die größte und unmittelbarste
bedrohung für unsere sicherheit ist
vom partner zur bedrohung seit dem 24
februar als russland seinen krieg
beginnt sehen das alle so nicht mehr nur
die osteuropäer
russland hat die ukraine angegriffen
russland ist jetzt eine bedrohung nicht
allein für europa nein für die ganze
nato das ist doch jetzt sehr klar
in den augen der nato so klar dass sie
reagieren muss mit einer beispiellosen
aufrüstung die eingreiftruppe der nato
bisher 40.000 soldaten soll auf 300.000
fast verachtfacht werden beschließt der
gipfel und der us präsident kündigte an
ein dauerhaftes hauptquartier in polen
zu errichten dauerhaft das hatten nato
staaten bisher ausgeschlossen
in dem moment in dem putin den frieden
in europa zerstört und das fundament der
internationalen ordnung angegriffen hat
steigern wir noch einmal unsere
anstrengungen
die anstrengung zu steigern das fordert
auch der ukrainische präsident lenski
per video von der nato was er meint
schwere waffen die nato antwortet dazu
mit einem versprechen die ukraine so
lange zu unterstützen wie nötig wie
genau sagt sie heute nicht
die ukraine hofft weiter auf mehr waffen
die nato macht versprechungen dabei
wollen wir mit der
bundesverteidigungsministerium
ministerin reden guten abend verlangt
recht
wir sehen dass es auch im nato ländern
zunehmend die bereitschaft gibt eben
auch modernes westliches gerät zu
liefern deutschland tut das jetzt zum
beispiel mit dem panzerhaubitzen jetzt
gibt es berichte dass spanien angeboten
hat zehn leopard 1 panzern zu schicken
haben sie darüber mit ihrer spanischen
amtskollegin heute gesprochen
bei mir liegt dieses angebot oder bzw
diese anforderung noch nicht vor aber
ich habe jetzt gleich im anschluss ein
gespräch mit ihr und da werden wir
sicherlich auch diese frage erörtern das
wäre ein paradigmenwechsel wenn dann
kampfpanzer geliefert wurden
bisher hat kein land
panzer westlicher bauart geliefert und
deswegen wird es interessant sein ob es
dieses angebot diesen wunsch von spanien
tatsächlich gibt aber was jetzt wichtig
ist ist dass darüber hinaus auch waffen
geliefert werden die jetzt sofort
bedient werden können denn die ukraine
ist dringend darauf angewiesen jetzt
über waffen zuvor zu verfügen und
deswegen haben wir uns in deutschland
und in den niederlanden ja auch noch mal
entschieden zusätzliche panzerhaubitzen
2000 zu liefern sowie vom kollegen rest
mit of gewünscht es kommt jetzt darauf
an auch wenn ich damit ziemlich an die
grenzen dessen gehe was ich auch noch
verantworten kann um die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung gewährt eine
hausecke meine hobbys ist aber kein
kampfpanzern und an denen mangelt ist ja
auch diesen schlachten die man da jetzt
ein don was zieht ganz gewaltig also
wäre die bundesregierung bereit die
spanier den spaniern zuzustimmen dass
sie dieses deutsche gerät diese
kampfpanzer schicken
also wir werden jetzt warten ob spanien
tatsächlich diesen antrag stellt und
dann werden wir in der bundesregierung
beraten und auch zügig entscheiden aber
was die ukraine jetzt braucht es
artillerie- die weitreichend ist und die
sehr präzise ist und deswegen haben wir
uns ja auch entschieden mit
großbritannien und mit den usa zusammen
mehrfach raketenwerfer zu schicken das
system maß das kann jetzt auch zügig
erfolg wird noch ausgebildet das ist
wichtig dass die ukrainischen soldaten
auch daran ausgebildet sind und dann
eben auch diese möglichkeit haben also
neben den panzerhaubitzen 2000 mehrfach
raketenwerfer die geparden werden noch
geliefert und auch das system iris t
also die ukraine wird unterstützt mit
allen möglichkeiten die wir haben wenn
man erlebe auch bei anderen nato
partnern bei den alliierten diesen
wunsch jetzt schnell liefern so wenn man
geparden panzer liefert warum dann nicht
auch die 100 mörder oder 88 leo panzer
die bei rheinmetall rumstehen die würden
ja gerne und haben ja auch schon in
einem haben ja auch schon beantragt die
aushilfen zu dürfen
also der gepard ist ein
flugabwehrkanonen panzer also in dem
baum ist schon ersichtlich um was es
geht es geht eben darum abzuwehren und
deswegen es sind auch diese gefahren
werden diese gefahren in die ukraine
geliefert darauf kommt es an eben auch
sich gegen diese angriffe zum beispiel
in bezug auf kritische infrastruktur
wehren zu können darauf kommt es an
jetzt sehr schnell zu liefern deswegen
die geparden ich habe andere systeme
aufgezeigt wir sind in ständigem
austausch mit der ukraine was sie
brauchen und da wo wir können
unterstützen wir aber warum betont man
da dieses abwehren ist nicht jede waffe
die im moment in die ukraine geliefert
wird schätze ich eine verteidigungswaffe
also ich bin im engen austausch und ich
glaube der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister kann sehr gut
abschätzen was er denn dringend braucht
und sein wunsch an uns war eben jetzt
noch mal zusätzlich panzerhaubitzen er
will auch ausdrücklich dieses gebaren
diesen gefahren haben um eben kritische
infrastruktur zu schützen und deswegen
immer in der abstimmung mit der ukraine
und auch mit unseren verbündeten und
noch mal wir machen keine deutschen
alleingänge sondern wir stimmen uns mit
unseren verbündeten ab und noch kein
anderes land hat
kampfpanzer westlicher bauart geliefert
da sind die deutschen auch in der
produktion auch weit vorne insofern
läuft das dann diese frage geben auch
schnell auf deutsche panzer zu der
gepard der hat jetzt bei maschinen
kanonen an bord der kann auch bodenziele
beschießen mit einer gewaltigen
feuerkraft wenn man davor keine bedenken
hat warum dann nicht auch andere panzer
geht es darum zu putin sagen zu können
auch wir schießen nur in die luft oder
das ist ja nur für infrastruktur weil
faktisch kann der auch ganz anderes
dieser gefahr
der gepard kann richtig große löcher
schießen da haben sie natürlich recht
aber als ausgerichtet darauf die
flugabwehr zu sichern und das ist auch
das was die ukraine will sie hat eben
diese angriffe sie will ihre kritische
infrastruktur zu schützen und deswegen
geht es auch nicht darum jetzt nicht
einfallen zu lassen was andere oder was
der eine oder andere sich einfallen
lässt niemand die ukraine auch noch
unterstützen sind könnten sondern wir
müssen doch darauf hören was sie jetzt
wollen und das ist der ausdrückliche
wunsch kritische infrastruktur schützen
weitreichende präzise artillerie und
deswegen unterstützen wir mit
panzerhaubitzen mit mehrfach
raketenwerfern mit geparden mit iris t
und dabei und noch viel viel mehr
darüber hinaus mittlerweile ist die
liste dessen was wir geliefert haben ja
schon an den corine einsehbar und das
macht deutlich das ist sehr beachtliche
unterstützung nur die panzer liefern
wenig und die wollen die ukraine auch
sehr sehr dringend und das schon sehr
lange
wir sorgen dafür dass die ukraine panzer
bekommt nämlich panzer sowjetischer
bauart an denen dann auch sofort
gekämpft werden körperliche ringtausch
bisher noch kein einziges mal klappt
gibt welche nicht abgegeben hat schon
längst panzer abgegeben hat abgegeben
und wir sorgen dafür dass diese lücke
aufgefüllt wird ich war jetzt auch am
gipfel noch mal ganz intensiv mit meinem
griechischen kollegen und auch mit
meinem slowakischen kollegen im
austausch und auch da gibt es
fortschritte auch da bleiben wir dafür
sorgen dass die ukraine schnell panzer
geliefert bekommt panzer an denen dann
auch sofort gekämpft werden kann und wir
helfen beim schließen der lücken gibt es
ja auch bei der schnellen eingreiftruppe
der nato die gewaltig aufgestockt werden
soll da sind die deutschen mit 15.000
soldaten
+65 für mich das richtig gesehen habe
flugzeugen und 20 marineeinheiten und
mit dabei haben wir die überhaupt
wir können sicherstellen dass das was
wir zu sagen in der nato auch dann
bereitgestellt werden kann
selbstverständlich haben wir das vorher
geprüft und es ist wichtig dass jeder in
dieser allianz weiß wir sind ein
verlässlicher partner wir stehen zu
unserer verpflichtung in der nato wir
sind bündnis armee und wir werden das
auch gewährleisten und das ist doch das
wichtige signal das auch von diesem
gipfel hier ausgesendet wird dass die
nato stark ist dass sie zusammen steht
und dass sie auch bereit ist den
herausforderungen vor denen wir doch
ganz aktuell stehen auch gerecht zu
werden durch veränderungen und jahr dazu
gehört dann dass wir auch zusätzliche
soldatinnen und soldaten schicken mit
boten mit schiffen mit flugzeugen aber
auch dass wir beispielsweise den kreis
der nato mitglieder erweitern werden
also auch das ein ganz klares signal wir
sind stark wir schützen einander und
stehen zueinander sagt die
bundesverteidigungsministerium vielen
dank verlangt
ich danke ihnen
das gespräch aus dem minuten
aufgezeichnet
themawechsel an diesem wochenende
starten die ersten bundesländer in die
sommerferien
wer eine flugreise gebucht hat kann nur
hoffen dass die auch stattfindet und
sollte überlegen ob man klappt für
köchin und thermoskanne mitnimmt um
gegebenenfalls drei stunden wartezeit in
der security schlange zu überstehen
irgendwie scheinen weder
flughafenbetreiber noch airlines bedacht
zu haben dass die vielen verkauften
flugtickets auch viele passagiere mit
sich bringen es aber an personal fehlt
um sie abzufertigen hinzu kommt dass
eine frei floaten der korona welle auch
vor pilotinnen sturz oder towerlotse
nicht halt macht das flugchaos
beschäftigt jetzt auch die
bundesregierung
elisabeth schmidt berichtet
schadensbegrenzung mehr hat die
taskforce flughäfen vorerst nicht im
gepäck drei bundesminister verkünden
eine lösung die nicht aus der
bundesrepublik kommt sondern aus der
türkei etwa 2000 arbeitskräfte von dort
sollen den airport kollaps ihr jetzt
abwenden den nötigen aufenthalts und
arbeitserlaubnisse erteilen wir sehr
schnell dazu hat sich mein haus schon
bereit erklärt und wir sorgen dafür dass
es kein lohndumping gibt und auch die
beschäftigten gut untergebracht werden
ausgeschlossen sei eine neue
finanzspritze für die luftfahrtbranche
während der pandemie gab es
milliardenhilfen vom staat hilfen die
jobs eigentlich retten sollten was nicht
geht ist und das sage ich auch ein blick
auf den öffentlichen eindruck das
unternehmen probleme schaffen und dem
staat das sozusagen politur gekippt wird
letztlich ist es ein
privatwirtschaftliches problem das nur
durch die unternehmen gelöst werden kann
das problem sieht derzeit so aus
düsseldorf heute nachmittag
kartenspielen stadt abheben an deutschen
flughäfen fielen etwa 7200 fachkräfte
beim check in bei der gepäckabfertigung
bei der sicherheitskontrolle
wir sind sehr früh losgefahren und dann
hier angekommen aber der schalter der
wahrheit nicht geöffnet also hat das
eigentlich nichts gebracht unsere flüge
wollen heute schon zweimal animiert und
leider müssen jetzt noch stunden auf
unsere koffer warten problem hausgemacht
während der pandemie drängten
luftfahrtunternehmen beschäftigte einem
aufhebungsvertrag zuzustimmen teilweise
mit hohen abfindungen
der frankfurter flughafenbetreiber
fraport strich 4000 stellen die
lufthansa weltweit 32.000 jetzt ein
verknüpftes schreiben ab bitte an die
passagiere wir können uns dafür bei
ihnen nur entschuldigen und wollen dabei
auch ganz ehrlich sein in den nächsten
wochen mit weiter steigenden
passagierzahlen ob urlaub oder
geschäftsreisen wird sich die situation
kurzfristig kaum verbessern
die branche hat unterschätzt dass
menschen die abgewandert sind nicht mehr
zurückkommen andere branche haben sich
sehr bewusst dafür entschieden diese
leute lange zu halten und wirklich bis
an die schmerzgrenze zu gehen damit wir
eben jetzt einen guten neustart haben da
sind hier versäumnisse passiert
versäumnisse die jetztzeit kosten auf
neue flughafen mitarbeiter aus der
türkei müssen eine
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung bestehen heißt
die wohnsitze ihre vergangenen jahre an
geben auch nach strafverfahren wird
gesucht das kann dauern
das was jetzt getan wird herr mit
einstellungs prämien so schnell wie
möglich gucken mitarbeiter wieder
einzustellen wenn das thema eben mit den
ausländischen kräften jetzt heranzuholen
ich mache mir ehrlich gesagt keine
hoffnung dass wir das thema im sommer
wirklich so in den griff bekommen allein
der airport düsseldorf erwartet in den
sommerferien drei millionen passagiere
die neue reiselust zur besten reisezeit
eine geduldsprobe an den flughäfen
in frankreich ist heute der größte
terror prozesse der geschichte des
landes zu ende gegangen damit beginnen
die nachrichten von hanna zimmermann im
prozess um die anschläge in paris im
november 2015 hat das gericht am abend
die urteile verkündet der
hauptangeklagte salat islam wurde wegen
mordes und versuchten mordes zu einer
lebenslangen haftstrafe verurteilt ab
der slum gilt als einziger überlebender
der terrorzelle 18 weitere angeklagte
wurden wegen taten im zusammenhang mit
terrorismus schuldig gesprochen
den anschlägen am 13 november 2015
töteten islamistische terroristen
insgesamt 130 menschen hunderte wurden
verletzt
die ukraine und russland haben den
bislang größten gefangenenaustausch seit
kriegsbeginn vorgenommen auf beiden
seiten seien 144 soldaten aus der
gefangenschaft entlassen worden darunter
95 ukrainische kämpfer die das stahlwerk
in mario pohl verteidigt hatten
unterdessen ist der russische präsident
putin zum ersten mal seit beginn des
krieges wieder auf einer auslandsreise
heute in turkmenistan in der westlichen
sanktionen will er im energiebereich
enger mit zentralasiatischen ländern
zusammenarbeiten
in der eu sollen neu zugelassene autos
ab 2035 nicht mehr von herkömmlichen
verbrenner motoren angetrieben werden
darauf haben sich die eu-umweltminister
geeinigt klimaneutraler autoverkehr ist
ein zentrales vorhaben um die eu
emissionsziele zu erreichen über das
verbot von benzin diesel und gasautos
waren sich die minister einig die
allerdings mit klimaneutral produzierten
synthetischen kraftstoffen umgegangen
wird soll jetzt die eu-kommission prüfen
dann günther ist zum ministerpräsidenten
schleswig holsteins wiedergewählt worden
mit den stimmen von cdu und grünen wurde
der 48 jährige in seinem amt bestätigt
zudem wurde das neue kabinett der
schwarz grünen koalition vorgestellt und
vereidigt von acht ministerien
übernehmen die cdu fünf die grünen drei
und ein ganz ähnliches bild heute in
nordrhein westfalen dort wurde das neue
schwarz grüne kabinett von
ministerpräsident wüst vereidigt
darunter auch bisherige
regierungsmitglieder die innenminister
reul und gesundheitsminister laumann
insgesamt gehen acht posten an die cdu
hier an die grünen
der nordrhein-westfälische
gesundheitsminister hat es seit nunmehr
neun wochen mit streikenden personal der
universitätskliniken zu tun die
gewerkschaften erwarten von ihm
unterstützung im tarifstreit und er muss
sich sorgen wie sehr die streiks auch
die gesundheitliche versorgung im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
gefährden ambulante behandlungen wurden
bereits reduziert operationen abgesagt
ganze stationen geschlossen an allen
sechs uni kliniken des landes sind die
pflegekräfte im streik was wir fordern
das wird ja eigentlich seit der pandemie
landauf landab gesagt dass die
arbeitsbedingungen der branche
verbessert gehören auch um den
personalmangel entgegenzuwirken
dominik marcel berichtet
eigentlich würde carola peschl heute
wieder entscheiden um welchen patienten
sie sich kümmern kann und wen sie erst
mal ignorieren muss auf der
intensivstation der uniklinik münster
aufwühlendes aus dem geliebten
krankenhausalltag berichten auch ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen die überlastung
ist so groß dass sie in nordrhein
westfalen nicht mehr bereit sind sie
einfach hinzunehmen stattdessen streiken
und demonstrieren
in der notaufnahme wenn die kollegen
keine zeit mehr haben sich um
gleichzeitig alle patienten zu kümmern
die reinkommen sie müssen sich eine aus
sekunden das ist meiner ansicht nach
eine weiche triage gucken um ihn kümmern
sie sich zuerst und zwar immer um den am
schlechtesten geht und alle anderen
können über das können sie sonst nicht
schaffen und das ist einfach es können
dann muss man muss gucken dass alle
überleben und wirklich darum kämpfen
dass diese patienten überleben und
patienten bei dem mann nicht mehr retten
kann müssen alleine versterben weil
keine zeit dafür da ist diese würdig und
gut zu verabschieden und auch mit den
angehörigen da würde ich und gut
umzugehen und ich finde dass es was das
kann einfach nicht sein
entlastung mehr personal fordern die
krankenhaus mitarbeitenden doch die
fronten sind verhärtet seit neun wochen
läuft der streik bereits und nicht nur
pflegerinnen und pfleger auch die
unikliniken argumentieren mit dem
patientenwohl in bonn warten rund 1000
patienten auf dringend benötigte
operationen die nicht stattfinden können
weil zu viel personal leben streikt
kritisiert der leiter der
unfallchirurgie und außerdem das problem
ist dass diese pflegekräfte gar nicht in
deutschland verfügbar sind das heißt es
braucht eine politische entscheidung zu
sagen
es muss eine reduktion von
krankenhausbetten in deutschland mit
einer umverteilung der pflegekräfte
geben damit in den krankenhäusern wo
spezialisierte medizin gemacht wird auch
genügend pflegekräfte vorhanden sind es
gibt genügend pflegekräfte antworten die
streikenden viele hätten allerdings
frustriert hingeschmissen vom land
fordern sie dass die neue regierung den
uni kliniken finanziell unter die arme
greift damit es eben entlastung geben
kann und nicht alles beim alten bleibt
bei einem system das überfordert es
macht uns einfach auch krank und wenn
wir nicht mehr da sind wir dann da das
ist die frage
sie wollen durchhalten im klinikalltag
und im tarifstreit die pandemie habe
ihren alltag schonungslos offen gelegt
nun muss sich endlich etwas ändern
und wir blicken in die usa welche rolle
spielte donald trump beim sturm aufs
kapital war er treibende kraft hinter
diesen putschversuch oder billigte
zumindest die absehbare gewalt gibt es
dafür genügend belege um ihn anzuklagen
das so gab es jetzt den washingtoner
untersuchungsausschuss einen
denkwürdigen auftritt eine junge frau
die eng mit trump zusammenarbeitete und
die inzwischen unter polizeischutz steht
weil sie bereit war gegen ihn auszusagen
was sie nun öffentlich erzählte hat es
in sich aus washington benjamin daniel
es herrscht zimmertemperatur im saal und
doch spielt cassidy hutchinson der
schweiz im gesicht die gerade mal mitte
20 jährige sagt aus traut sich also was
sich viele ihrer ex kollegen die doppelt
oder dreimal so alt sind nicht trauen so
berichtet sie beispielsweise dass trump
am 6 januar metalldetektoren auf dem
gelände auf dem er seine rede hielt
abbauen lassen wolle um auch bewaffneten
anhängern den eingang ermöglichen dazu
wurde auch eine im vorfeld
aufgezeichnete aussage von ihr
eingespielt
trump sagte so etwas wie es ist mir
scheißegal dass sie waffen haben sie
sind ja nicht gegen mich gerichtet baute
detektoren ab lasst meine leute rein
dass sie zum kapitol marschieren können
nach seiner rede so hutchinson bestand
darauf dass ihn der secret service zum
kapitol fährt ein agent entgegnete dass
das zu gefährlich sei
der präsident hat sich im auto nach
vorne gelehnt um das lenkrad herum zu
reißen der agent ergriff seinen arm und
sagte so nehmen sie ihre hand vom
lenkrad wir fahren zurück zum westring
nicht zum kapitol
the tramp versuchte daraufhin mit seiner
anderen hand den agenten im halsbereich
zu packen
kontrollverlust beim damals mächtigsten
mann der freien welt der stellte auf
seiner social media plattform klar dass
das natürlich alles quatsch sei er wisse
ja kaum wer diese cassidy hutchinson ist
wohlgemerkt es geht um die rechte hand
seines damaligen stabschefs ihr büro lag
wenige schritte vom oval office entfernt
immer mehr details kommen also ans licht
und man sollte meinen dass die
republikanische partei sich von ihrem
anführer los sagt doch genau das
gegenteil scheint der fall zu sein gibt
bisher keine wirkliche abwendung von
donald trump und das hängt damit
zusammen dass die etablierteren
republikanischen partei vertreterinnen
und vertreter einfach angst vor der wahl
bevölkerung haben vor der ungeheuren
aggressivität bis hin zu offenen
gewaltandrohung sie haben vor der
parteibasis eine heidenangst diese
parteibasis folgt donald trump und sie
ist durch ihn radikalisiert worden dabei
gibt es in den reihen der grand old
party mit blick auf die
präsidentschaftswahlen durchaus denkbare
gegenkandidaten mit einer rückkehr zu
früheren gemäßigteren partei werten
rechnen experten allerdings nicht denn
allen sei klar wer nicht trumps weiße
nationalen ideologie vertreter habe
keine chance da sieht man niemandem
besser als an dem gründer von florida de
santis der als moderator umweltschützer
in der republikanischen partei einmal
angefangen hat 2012 als er zuerst in das
abgeordnetenhaus gewählt wurde aber seit
seiner wahl als gouverneur von florida
2018 sicht vollständig ein radikales
trump programm zur eigen gemacht hat zum
teil sogar versucht hat monaten noch von
rechts außen zu überholen
und so geht die unruhe nach dem sturm
war trump schwebt noch immer über die
bühne die ihm seine republikaner wohl
auch in zukunft geben werden und selbst
wenn sein tanz irgendwann vorbei sein
sollte seine ideen werden weiterleben
[Musik]
und jetzt nochmal hanna zunächst ein
blick auf die deutsche wirtschaft mit
einer meldung die so nicht erwartet
wurde die inflation in deutschland ist
laut ersten schätzungen im juni
überraschend geringer ausgefallen als im
mai eine teuerungsrate von 7,6 prozent
meldet das statistische bundesamt fragen
wir nach bei valerie haller in frankfurt
da kein beim ein oder anderen jetzt die
leise hoffnung nach einer möglichen
trendwende auf gibt es denn grund für
optimismus
eher weniger in ihren teil dazu
beigetragen haben nämlich vermutlich
tank rabatt und das neun euro ticket das
sorgt schlicht und ergreifend für
entlastung und das macht sich eben
entsprechend auch in der inflationsrate
bemerkbar aber beides läuft aus darum
muss man eher davon ausgehen dass die
hohe inflation bleibt also entlastung ja
entwarnung nein stärkster treiber waren
auch im juni wieder die kosten für
energie plus 38 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat deutlich teurer wurden
auch lebensmittel mit fast 13 prozent
energie und nahrung sind beides produkte
auf die man nicht verzichten kann darum
trifft die hohe inflation besonders
menschen mit niedrigen einkommen
seit zwei jahren haben viele menschen
nicht mehr das einkommen was sie vor
krone hatten also achten an ganz vielen
stellen bei der energie aber auch beim
einkauf genau darauf was sie ausgeben
und das heißt aber auch viele menschen
haben da kein einsparpotenzial mehr in
berlin laufen schon die diskussionen um
weitere entlastungen bundeskanzler
scholz will kommende woche zusammen mit
arbeitnehmer und arbeitgebervertretern
darüber beraten wie die inflation in den
griff zu bekommen ist entscheidend für
entlastungen wird sein wie sich die
inflation weiter entwickelt viele
ökonomen rechnen in der zweiten
jahreshälfte mit allmählichen
preisrückgang das jedoch die inflation
so tief fällt wie vor corona daran
glaubt selbst die europäische
zentralbank nicht lang kavallerie für
diese einschätzung
dass die aktuelle inflation die lage
gerade für alle menschen mit geringem
einkommen verschärft das erklärte auch
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband bei
der vorstellung seines aktuellen
armutsbericht demnach waren im
vergangenen jahr 13 8 millionen menschen
von armut bedroht da sein 600.000 mehr
als vor corona und wird in dem bericht
vor allem mit den wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen der pandemie begründet
der frühere vorsitzende der fdp martin
bangemann ist tot er starb im alter von
87 jahren als leidenschaftlichen
liberalen streiter für die
marktwirtschaft und großen europäer
würdigte fdp chef lindner den ehemaligen
bundeswirtschaftsminister
meinem mann war zudem eu
industriekommissar und von 1985 bis 88
vorsitzender der fdp
zu den lottozahlen die lauten
21 22 24 40 45 48 und die superzahl 8
alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
bei der schwimm-em in budapest gab es
heute gleich zwei medaillen für das
deutsche team leonie beck holte silber
über 10 kilometer im freiwasser und
verfehlte bolt denkbar knapp um nur fünf
zehntelsekunden schneller war die
niederländerin von rosendahl die zweite
medaille holte wenig später florian
wellbrock und zwar bronze über die
gleiche distanz gold und silber gingen
an die italiener patronelli und ac n a
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es mit dem auslandsjournal
weiter darin unter anderem eine
reportage unserer kriegsreporter und
katrin eigendorf die ukrainische kämpfer
begleitet hat und außerdem empfehlen wir
ihnen das heute journal update gegen 00
35 mit nazan charakter mir und heute
journal gibt es dann morgen wieder mit
hanna kier christian sievers auf
wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja was sind das aktuell für
temperaturen schon seit dem wochenende
in skandinavien heute gab es im norden
lapplands 33 grad normal sind der
temperatur und aktuell von 17 18 grad
wir liegen also über zehn grad höher als
normal was passierte aktuell wir haben
ein tief über den britischen inseln ein
hoch über sibirien
dazwischen transportiert der jetstream
das stark wind band in der höhe die
heiße luft bis weit in den norden uns
beschäftigt aktuell dieses tief das im
südosten die gewitter bringt jetzt in
der nacht da verlagert sich die gefahr
von lokalem starkregen in den äußersten
osten des landes im westen ist die nacht
meist klar die temperaturen sinken
morgen früh auf 18 grad in der gewitter
luft und 12 grad am alpenrand
morgen geht es dann verbreitet wieder
hinauf auf um die 30 grad nur in den
höheren berglagen an den alpen und im
nordosten ist es mit 22 bis 25 grad
etwas kühler hier liegt noch die wolkige
luft mit schauern und gewittern aus der
nacht sonst startete tag oft sonnig
nachmittags da ziehen zum einen aber
schauer und gewitter aus dem nordosten
ab es gibt neue einzelne gewitter über
den mittelgebirgen und zwischen
niederrhein und alben entwickeln sich
neue schauer und gewitter lokal auch mit
starkregen und sturmböen die gehören
nämlich zu einer kaltfront hier die dann
in der nacht auf freitag über das land
sieht in etwa bis zur elbe vorankommen
am freitag selbst bringt diese
vielleicht etwas regen die trockenen
regionen in den osten des landes am
samstag und am sonntag ist es dann aber
schon wieder trocken und mit bis 31 grad
gibt es ein sommerwochenende